[Music]
if you're gonna be the queen well you've
got to live like royalty and she and her
man jay z's seem to have their eyes set
on an unbelievable palace p and jay-z
may soon own this thirty
thousand-square-foot bel-air mansion
according to page six the couple put in
a 120 million dollar bid for the newly
constructed modern home and get this
it's got bulletproof windows be a
bedroom 11 back home might just be big
enough for the growing family expecting
twins likely arriving in June the two
acre property features four pools a spa
hot tub and steam room and lots of
outdoor lounging space there is also a
basketball court room for a recording
studio separate staff quarters and a
garage big enough to park 15 cars
complete perched up on a hill with a
view of Los Angeles mr. and mrs. Carter
would have some famous neighbors like
j.lo and Jen Aniston the couple has
reportedly wanted to relocate to Los
Angeles from New York for more privacy
and is set to be looking for a private
kindergarten 45 year old Blue Ivy what
we know about Beyonce home is where her
family is I'm always on the road so when
they come with me that really is what
makes it home cuz I select by the way
quick prop to Beyonce putting her money
to good use she just announced her
formation scholarship which will go to a
young woman at four different chosen
ecology
[Music]
you